[Music]
they came
from across the uk to party illegally
these are the scenes of a lockdown rave
three
thousand people descending on a village
in south wales
causing widespread disruption the party
started in the early hours of sunday
and carried on throughout the bank
holiday weekend
the loud music and swarms of cars have
left the locals furious
50 if not more was going up and down the
street vans
big you know the ones you get did you
put the horses in the back
then because they couldn't go up the top
they were turning around to back down
up down up down all night and what about
the sound of the music
that's it this has turned into what is
now a significant police operation
arrests have been made and the party has
ended
south wales police branded it as totally
unacceptable
and are looking at all pieces of
legislation
in a statement the police federation
which represents officers in england and
wales
said these are already existing officers
which are being pulled away from other
duties to manage those ignorant enough
to ignore the guidance designed to keep
them and others safe
many officers dispersing large
gatherings are often subject to abuse
and violence from the selfish
individuals
who choose to attend these and this is
completely unacceptable
we are not society's punching bags
but it isn't just in wales where
predominantly young people are raving
and breaking the rules
in norfolk police shut down an all-night
unlicensed music event
which hosted more than 500 people in
leeds and essex
thousands of pounds worth of music
equipment were seized by police
which they believe was set to be used
for illegal parties
[Music]
it was just on friday the government
introduced new measures
to clamp down on such illegal gatherings
now
organizers can receive a fine of up to
10
000 pounds those who attend and those
who don't wear face coverings where it's
mandatory
could be given a 100 pound fine
the home secretary lashed out at the
organizers of these parties
reminding them they are not above the
law the kovid 19 pandemic
may have frustrated many with festivals
wiped out
and numerous summer events across the
country cancelled
but it's illegal parties like these that
are the perfect scenario
for the spread of this infectious
disease insomnia rasheed sky news